have you ever dated a coworker not
dated um that's all I'll say have you
ever had sex in a public place let's see
I have sex in like a hot tub and like a
storage closet in like a hostal in
Portugal
okay if I was to say to you someone had
sex in the office I would be like go off
like ooh scandy like I love a little
scand in Al where would you maybe
suggest a good place to have sex in an
office well there's just so many rooms
in an office you know there's a lot of
these like solo rooms the part about
having sex in an office is also like the
thrill of being caught it's like so it's
not like the most private it's not like
foolproof but if it's like there's a
chance that's kind of fun have you had
sex in an office no I have not